[Music]
does the jingle get old you think people
are hearing it's my point of view
because people do say sing it to me at
cons and things like that it's probably
comforting maybe or maybe it's annoying
I'd be like oh my God he made his own
jingle how cheesy no I have a lot of
podcasts have Jingles do that yeah
yeah all right thank you
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum thank you for joining
us
um Ryan welcome hi you look handsome
today thank you good beard length thank
you I'm going to the premiere for your
audience tonight should I is this beard
okay is this enough it's not too big no
it's not big at all okay good no no I
shaved my neck so it's not real hairy in
the Hendersons no and it's nice it's
clean uh guys thank you for listening uh
if you want to support the podcast and
you're enjoying it uh patreon.com inside
of you become a patron thank you I will
message you after a lot of perks and fun
things different tiers uh the inside of
you online store has tons of Smallville
stuff signed by me Funko Pops inside of
you tumblers all that stuff
um that's that I'll be in Wales doing a
con early May then I'll be in Virginia
Beach Tidewater
uh the Thai Water con I believe so get
out there and see me say hello it'll be
fun whales I'll be with Kristen crook my
good buddy Kristen crook nice yeah yeah
it's really nice
I haven't been to Wales I would like to
go yeah it's nice it's fun yeah but I'm
usually there just to sign and see all
the fans and then then I [__] off read
some big words yeah
English people just sound so much
smarter no matter what they're saying
like I go yeah I just went to the canyon
store like what an idiot yeah I just
went over to the canyon store let's pop
down the shop yeah it popped out of the
shop and I got myself you know went at a
point a bottle of water yeah what what
if you're English I'm sorry
uh thank you for listening Taran killum
is on the show if you don't know him
listen this guy he's so funny he's so
easy to talk to some guests come on I'm
like
I wish I was this guy's friend I wanted
to call me a friend you know I want to
hang out with him he's just a great guy
and has a lot of cool stories and a lot
of things to say so I think you're gonna
really enjoy this
um and that's what I like about this
podcast sometimes you're listening to
folks you don't know you might not know
him
but I think you're going to like him a
hell of a lot after didn't you like him
I liked him he was great I know he liked
him I was looking for this one I you
know found out about him on snls a lot
of people did and he's just he's just a
great performer great funny man funny
funny guy did King George and Hamilton
too isn't that crazy
he could sing yeah
that boy can sing uh thanks for
listening the handles are inside of you
podcast on Instagram and Facebook and
Twitter is at inside EU right now I
[__] that up I decided to be pod on
Twitter inside of your podcast on
Instagram and Facebook thank you there
we go thank you Ryan done what would I
do write a review if you like the
podcast truly helps the podcast and uh
let's just get into it man we don't talk
too much maybe a few minutes at the
start but uh you probably fast forwarded
let's get inside of Taran kill him it's
my point of view
you're listening listening to inside of
you with Michael Rosenberg
foreign
[Music]
was not recorded in front of a live
studio audience yeah every actor and
their mother wanted to do a podcast yeah
and I was like oh [__] because a lot of
these guys are way more famous than me
sure a smart list pops up but yes which
is called smart uh smartless yeah
smartless right and they and they you
know it's like they're all stars and
especially Jake Bateman for sure so for
sure who they they know everybody yeah
so they can get the biggest guests and
it's just like uh but you know it's
slowly but surely I got some traction
and then I got really it's loyal fans
loyal listeners from the beginning and
then it builds and it's like all right
now it's it's really worth doing yeah
um but like you know it's
I can't believe I'm doing it three years
I've interviewed like over 220 people
incredible it's crazy man yeah now
you're making me kind of feel weird I
feel good I hope I hope only proud it's
I'm proud it's just a direction I never
thought I'd go and I you know I was I
was doing a show and uh I was deleting
it and I was you know and then all of a
sudden uh I was like you know I don't
know if I want to do that anymore yeah
yeah and now I'm kind of like going do I
still want to do it maybe maybe I do
that's just I've been going through that
yeah but I like doing this I like
playing music I mean you're 40. yes sir
what are you gonna say you're gonna say
well just uh you your voice over career
alone is prolific in my opinion you know
what's funny about that it's it's the
hardest little click to get into and
you've done a lot of voice over work as
well some yeah I feel I'm on the
outskirts but I love it I love it and
it's hard it's hard to get into what
would happen is once my career started
taking off with live action stuff like
small villain movies and things I kind
of just didn't have time and they forgot
me
for the beginning of Smallville I got
more stuff like yeah you know
documentaries or things like that and
video games and as of about five years
ago
it just sort of stopped interesting I
still have to audition never works I've
auditioned for some big movies Ryan's
helped me put on yeah I've been very
close Ryan we've been very close nearly
there nearly there yeah that was a lot
of work for no reward no reward for me
no rewards for me uh it was it was
upsetting and then we had another one
remember the uh The Batman series yeah
you know uh it was uh they were doing a
new sorry Peter Brady I like it they
were doing it no you're great Peter we
all want to come to your party no uh but
um
I remember going you know call back with
him and everybody and uh you know I
think my Batman was really good yeah I
think they were really happy with Batman
yeah but the Bruce Wayne I don't think
they were happy with I could tell I was
like okay
listen to me Taryn oh yeah I want to
tell you right now at least that and
that was fine and I was like okay look
man and they're like no then there's two
two voices well I I did some stuff but I
mean R.I.P Kevin Kevin boy he's the best
of all yeah God yeah and
um that hurt that one hurt yeah it was a
shock man it was a shock because I
didn't know how sick Kevin Conroy was
for a while though I think yeah he had
stomach cancer his niece was in uh
growlings with me and there was of all
the fun people who'd come by and see a
show the most giddy I got was getting to
meet Kevin really yes oh God hold on a
second he's excited because the jacuzzi
guy's here oh no I'm excited hey hey hey
hey hey hey hey guys 98 Degrees please
you just jumped in the world not just a
good thing hi hi everybody for sure get
off the shed it's the best
um have you had a lot of success have
you been how do you deal with rejection
first of all
uh have you always dealt with it the
same way or was early on it was tough
tough and then you kind of got used to
it I find it harder now or or I or I
think
I think maybe in my 30s it wore on me
because I I I've been auditioning on and
off since I was about five years old for
a long time and I easily easily made it
to like 25 years I made it 20 years
going like yeah that's part of it
sometimes you get it sometimes you know
no big deal and now and as time is
fleeting and the sand drips Through The
Hourglass you're like is this worth my
time and to put because like pretty
early on I cut out commercials I I found
that pretty futile I was like I can't
drive across town at 4 pm in the
afternoon to sit in a room with 20
people who look you know ish like me
yeah to you know to go like
one more time
yeah thank you thank you okay thanks so
much I get that but you know what's
funny is
when I was auditioning for commercials I
had these things because I finally got
them fixed I got a retainer
and long hair and I was like an awkward
I was like in my early you know 20s in
New York yeah nobody wanted to see me on
camera really yeah I just no one wanted
to see me on camera I guess I was like
oh my gosh I did a lot of voice overs
okay not where I thought you were gonna
go with that they're gonna be like every
chips or soda commercial was mine just
because like a distinct look and long
hair and I think that's interesting I
think the first thing I got was bite the
burst only burst gum freshened your
mouth something like I think it was
burst or like awesome Trojan condoms
yeah I hear that I don't know I think I
did a bunch of that stuff that's great
but I was like doing a lot I couldn't
believe it it's like you know that I
never thought I'd be doing voiceovers
yeah I was doing Off-Broadway not making
any money and doing whatever I could I
know you've done Broadway Hamilton yeah
yeah it was I yeah I don't know you
still don't really I know how but it was
that was the best it was just it felt
like a contest winner all right we're
gonna get into that but you're back to
rejection great
um I got a rejection I got a rejection
story that that ties directly to you
kind of okay
um and and it really also is
it's the it's the like fork in the road
moment where I went from like
actor pilot season act you know
traditional Street con you know to
comedian and the last thing that I
tested for before I got mad tv was
Smallville I went to the studio for Pete
are you serious yeah yeah because I was
also repped by tall and Robbins for
management wow so like they were heavily
involved in that obviously and and and
went there and then yeah they and then
they changed changed the casting Dynamic
for those roles yeah
um but yeah so like that was I you know
that's a crazy small world we could have
been working together yeah we could have
had seven years together I know I know
actually Pete left I think after two or
three years okay they let him go had
enough yeah well I think that the
character I didn't think they were going
anywhere with the character sure you can
only go like oh my
yeah
yeah we make fun but we don't because
with Sam Jones who played Pete was was
great and we love him but uh there's an
episode in season one because we're
doing a re-watch show yeah yeah and we
watch them and we critique him but
there's a scene where he sees a dead
body fall out of a closet yeah he's like
in his response for some reason was
damn
who's that
I was like what
who's that yeah I mean like that's what
you do when a body falls that's what I
didn't do in the audition and that's why
I was rejected oh yeah and then that
rejection yeah led to
uh something I thought I'd immediately
get rejected for which is like a sketch
show because again I was like a funny
smart ass Class Clown kind of guy but no
improv stand-up training at that point
right but just auditioned for mad and
then that sent me down were you
surprised when you what was your
audition process like for Mad TV pretty
epic
um Nicole Garcia was casting and like I
did a pre-read for her and it was like
just raw energy and and and thankfully
she was like I like when you do this you
don't need to do that and so she kind of
gave me an edited version like she
helped me shape it a bit came in for
producers that worked came in for a
producer Workshop where a bunch of
people were there and they like cat did
chemistry stuff put people together and
mix and match were you improvising too
not really no that's that wasn't part of
it they gave you a script from a sketch
that they had done to see
um they just basically wanted to see
your characters your impressions
and then they give you a script to see
how how you could act basically I think
you know like can you be the straight
person in a sketch and and can you you
know are you good in front of camera
kind of thing was this the first season
or when did you come on no seven season
seven was my first and you were in only
you're working with Bobby Lee of course
got hired with Bobby yeah he got hired
season seven yes was he a nervous wreck
he was great he was funny I mean he's
one of my my favorite people who has
been on the podcast three or four times
yeah he and I likes that chemistry
that's where I first met him and yeah he
was high-end he's like yeah yeah yeah
yeah are you excited are you gonna do it
yeah
no my favorite like my favorite Bobby
Lee Story through that because like he
and I
kind of were the only two that tested it
Network together they ended up hiring
two other performers that year but but
Bobby was the only one there with me
then and it was at Fox and this is when
the Fox TV building had arcade machines
in the lobby do you remember this like
they had the alien one so Bobby and I
hung out after the test and just played
video games for like 30 minutes
like this is cool and they were walking
past you know these guys are still here
holding up the sides to their face eye
contact but no I I then randomly ran
into Bobby a week or two later after I'd
found out I got the job but didn't know
who else did and he was coming out of
Virgin mega store all right on this
version uh me too I mean you are yeah
this would be prime
the best time the best loved a good hand
yeah virgin mega store
um and I saw him coming out he's like I
was like hey man hey I I got it he's
like yeah yeah I got it I gotta have you
used it to get laid
no
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
and who couldn't use a few better coping
skills to be able to handle all of
life's curveballs look
if you're thinking of giving you therapy
a try better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
inside he was brought to you by rocket
money Ryan rocket money you want to save
money rocket money honestly this is this
is an easy sell you know I have to sell
it because I do this I want to watch a
program streaming but I don't have
bluebee or whatever they call it right
and so I go oh I'll just I'll I'll just
buy the Subscribe and I'll cancel it but
guess what happens right you forget and
they keep charging all of a sudden wow
that cost me sixty dollars to watch The
Dukes of Hazzard
whatever the hell you want to watch it's
an app that gathers up all these
unwanted subscriptions
and make sure that you don't pay for
them when you don't want to and they
you're now aware of it uh how much do
subscriptions really cost I think you
know most people think it's about 80 a
month right then they might save 80 but
you actually are closer to two hundred
dollars
so if you don't know how much money
you're spending rocket money is for you
rocket money is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spendings
and helps you lower your bills all in
one place over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions they forgot about and
chances are you're one of them like that
stars app just to watch that one show or
that free gaming trial you never
actually used that's what I'm saying
rocket money will quickly and easily
find your subscriptions for you and for
any you don't want to pay for anymore
you just hit cancel
and Rocket money will cancel it for you
it is that easy Ryan rocket money also
helps you manage all your finances in
one place and automatically categorize
your expenses so you can easily track
your budget in real time and also get
alerted if anything looks off over three
million people have used rocket money
saving the average person up to 720
dollars a year stop throwing your money
away cancel unwanted subscriptions and
manage your expenses the easy way by
going to
rocketmoney.com
inside that's rocketmoney.com inside
inside
who was uh Matt TV I'll ask you this
about SNL too but yeah the one person
who made you laugh the most I mean let's
say the for look they're all funny
they're all great you'll love them but
the one person who just cracked you up
Sasso yeah yeah we always will and will
also like Sasso and Mo Collins
they're all great but but Sasso and Mo
and then and then Sasso specifically
just because like
there was the least amount of age gap
between me and him and every other cast
member and um it was the year that
tenacious D's album had come out so like
I'm just a ball of nerves and like
feeling undeserving unward like what am
I doing here I'm a fraud and we'd hang
out in his dressing room and he'd play
the songs on guitar and we'd sing
together black would play the songs yeah
Jack Black did come did he he before
they performed Tenacious D perform that
year and it's maybe the most
embarrassing uh most embarrassed I've
ever felt why I was 19 so excited that
album was everything
there they had a little stage for the
music guest and they had to put like
temporary chairs I asked the producers
can I sit in those chairs and like turn
you're you're on the show you know and I
was like I want to sit front row and
they're like sure
um I did like this is embarrassing and I
haven't really ever admitted this in
public before I think but they played
rock your socks off yeah and I thought I
was being so clever and funny that
during the performance I slipped my
shoes off and took off my socks so that
when the song ended I threw my socks on
stage
like they'd rocked my socks off I I
don't think I think that's funny it was
okay and Jack of course because he's a
genius was like it worked
um and and so then Mike Hitchcock who is
writing on the show at the time and was
also very kind to me was I was like I
love it he's like well come meet him
they're great they're nice and I go in
Jack's sitting on the floor like uh
cross-legged like signing vinyls and
then Kyle gas is there sitting on the
couch talking to some friend their
managers in there and Mike comes in and
goes hey Jack how are you and they know
each other a little bit and Jack's like
good to see you buddy how you doing and
like this is Taryn he's so excited to me
he's a huge fan he's our newest cast
member he's only 19. Jackson like 19.
when I was your age you know
and they get to talking about things
that you know the mutual acquaintances
and I kind of sit down on this little
couch
and Mike and here talking and then Dave
Grohl walks in oh boy yeah yeah and I'm
like oh sh and Dave had played drums on
their album so he was playing drums for
them at the show
and I'm sitting on the couch and I'm
just like this is the drummer for
Nirvana I'm looking at the drummer for
Nirvana this is Foo Fighters but this is
the drummer of Nirvana and they're
talking everybody says hi and I'm just
like so Starstruck and in that time I
think Hitchcock had said goodbye and
left the room
and so I'm still there without kind of
my host guardian and but I just want to
watch all of it because I am kind of a
fly on the wall and gruel sits next to
me on this couch and he's catching up
with her manager and their other friends
and Kyle and he and I'm just sitting
there and Dave girl goes yeah yeah we're
out of my place in Virginia you know
it's great you just got a lot of space
and we do these barbecues and like the
beef is so good there we get these huge
steaks and you can kind of tell that I'm
like eavesdropping so he looks over and
like very kindly includes me and he's
like you know like huge steaks and I was
like oh I wouldn't know wasn't invited
already hating myself and he's like oh
man well maybe maybe next time I said
I'm not I promise you I am not
exaggerating any of this he's trying to
fit in I'm trying to I'm we do that to
be approved of course and and and
acknowledged and he already did too and
I just was not cool enough to be like oh
that's nice you man you know I'm like he
goes oh well maybe next time I go oh
thanks but um not allowed in the state
of Virginia
and he goes really why is that and I
said oh well I'm not uh legally allowed
to say let's let's just say it has
something to do with sodomy and cows
like just the most base dumb moronic
trying to be funny Grote like 19 year
old bro whatever love you after that no
I I no I'm in the moment I'm going like
shut up shut up shut up shut up shut up
stop stop shut up and at that horrible
whatever lame thing he's like all right
man and his body kind of shifts you know
and like now I'm stuck on the couch now
I'm even more Frozen for some reason you
think then I would like run out of there
crying but I'm even more Frozen
Michael McDonald walks in stop it
Michael McDonald not not uh What a Fool
Believes but Michael McDonald from Mad
TV
shows
like boys
um no Mike McDonald was on the show
um who I think they'd sent in to recruit
Jack to maybe be in a sketch as well as
perform music
and he's like hi Jack hey great to see
you I'm so happy to have you so excited
wondering if you and as he's talking he
makes eye contact with me and he pauses
and he goes what's Taryn doing here like
that and the room goes silent and
everybody looks over at me and Jack goes
yeah you can kind of tell his Knight
with the band and everybody laughs oh my
God I go sorry I just hit him in my
stand and I walk out of the room and
just was like were you were just
blushing uh so hot so hot all over here
and then like when you know Bobby and I
that first year we didn't even have like
a real dressing room we were just in
like a two Banger trailer in an Alleyway
you know and so like I went there and I
just like sat and just was like what is
wrong with you why couldn't you just be
cool and nice and shut it's not in our
nature I do the same thing yeah I
remember I had done a movie and John
Cusack was in it and I was at the lay
Lakers game and it's like the Chairman's
room
at halftime yes and I'm standing there
having a drink and Sandra Bullock walks
over to me and she goes oh my God you
are hilarious and I'm like
she could have seen sorority boys
that tanked and she goes and I go thank
you she goes cribs on MTV I go oh wow
you were so just naturally funny I just
loved you on that and I go oh my God
thank you so much and then
I'm talking you're on Kusa comes by and
he starts talking he goes hey how you
doing blah blah and I'm just standing
there and I'm like I'm still a little
star Starstruck of course and I go hey
we did Midnight in the Garden of Good
and Evil together and he goes oh yeah
yeah
and he just kind of like goes oh yeah
man cool I go yeah dude I was you were
great you're great in that I just
couldn't keep my mouth shut up but I was
excited he saw the nervous energy it
just changed the Dynamics I felt out of
place and he turned to Sandra and they
just started talking and I felt like all
of a sudden I disappeared I was standing
there I was listening but I was just
like yeah
and I walked away has that do you feel
you've ever been the John in that
situation because because that's what
I've been the cool guy who the other guy
who's like you feel it and you have to
shift out of it yeah
I I well I'm not that I'm cool but I've
been talking to some other
somebody who was in the industry that I
knew that I was talking to that someone
just came up comes up and goes hey and
you're saying hey how's it going I'm
trying to be nice and they just like
just like yeah and it just it's just
kind of awkward yeah I don't know what
to do so I get it but I'm like I worked
with you dumbass it's in my nature to
then make that person the most
comfortable that's what I try to do too
I try to go oh cool yeah are you are you
yeah what is up with you yeah tell me
everything hold on George Clooney yeah
but we don't want to talk to them yeah
yeah yeah we pretend we do yeah well yes
for sure
yeah but I don't yeah but but
no no I think you're right I think
you're like listen gun to my head do it
and I was like yeah no I'd like to talk
to this person that I know what I'm
comfortable with or whatever have shared
more shared experience with but that is
always drowned out by I don't want
anybody to feel bad yeah I I always feel
like that too I never want people to
feel embarrassed or yes nervous I'm
really good I'm really good at that I
really engaging that and you know my
mother is terrible about sensing your
room yeah yeah you know she'll go into a
room and won't know when to shut the f
up yeah and people will be like oh my
God where I'm like going if I I could
tell if I say something they're like
I'm like I'm like hey all right I'm out
I'm out or or I just I I you gotta know
when this stop yeah you know totally
um but a lot of people don't a lot of
people just they don't know when that
and in some ways that's an asset I think
yeah I think it is it's like it's not
ignorance is bliss but ignorance is
power in some ways you know what I mean
because you'll stop when you've achieved
what you need yeah at the ex you know
and it's not even at the expense of
anything else because you're not even
aware that someone else is being
expended maybe it's a gift yeah it's a
gift maybe to go and not feel the
embarrassment yes see I don't give a
[__] maybe those are the people who
really make it yeah I'm knocking on that
door I'm saying hello to this guy I
don't give a [__] I'm memorable and no
matter how much of an ass you appear to
be you don't give a [__] I'm absent of
Shame yeah do you get embarrassed easily
no not no no not anymore not after that
not after that Tenacious D conversation
I get embarrassed um it's usually
intelligence wise oh yeah if somebody
asks something or they say oh blah blah
and I don't know the answer or I'm just
I went blank I'm just like oh my God I
should know that oh you're that stupid
uh interesting so there was some
childhood it's from Child yeah yeah yeah
I understand that but I I would
I like watching people I like observing
people and like early on in my 20s or
something uh I couldn't even tell you
who it was but like I was like yeah you
know because then that thing and someone
was like I don't know what that is and
the power of that of like wait I have
the knowledge but you're making me feel
wrong for referencing something that's
incredible that I I took that on so in
those instances of like you know like
blah blah blah blah I haven't read that
I don't know it like there's such a
confident power there's a power to say
yeah it's just honesty yeah exactly if
like don't know it yet it happened uh
two nights ago I had a horror movie
night and I have friends over and this
is kind of a funny analogy or uh example
but uh we're sitting there and somebody
goes you know the glory hole and I go
you know what is a glory hole oh and
they like Go Frozen bomb shut up you
know what a glory hole is I go is it the
vagina it's like the glory okay you're
in the glory hole yeah they're like no
everybody was like stunned they couldn't
believe and I get it but I was like I
never I never got it and he goes wait
there's this horror movie called
glorious and in the movie there's a
bathroom stall and there's a hole in it
I go I watched it they go yeah that's a
glory hole and I go
oh I'm sorry you guys knew what a glory
hole was we did so like in yeah an
effort of honesty I felt that I was I am
surprised but then at the same time
isn't it interesting that you need to
feel bad for not knowing what a horrible
thing that is yes
yeah and maybe I'm most frustrated uh
pig is that it was called glorious and
not [__]
connects to [__] thank you when
there is a a Academy award-winning movie
called Glory that I promise you has very
little to do I believe uh uh uh civil I
think one of them right yeah I think so
um oh this is great God
um anyway let's pitch [__]
inside of you is brought to you by
wondery Gabrielle Union's strive for the
Perfection her father always demanded
but as a dark-skinned black girl she
never felt like she was enough even the
rich is a podcast from wondery that
tells the jaw-dropping stories about the
tumultuous lives of the world's Elite
from the greatest family dynasties to
pop culture Superstars their newest
season is all about the Teen Movie icon
Gabrielle Union after spending her
childhood trying to assimilate and
breaking into historically racist
industry Gabrielle thought her success
meant someone else had to fail but when
she's faced with hard choices Beyond her
control she realizes that the only way
to find real success is to come together
and build community
host Brooke and orisha will take you
through her life how she shook off her
need for Perfection found her true self
and created the life she always wanted
follow even the rich wherever you get
your podcasts you can listen ad-free on
Amazon music or wondery app this podcast
is brought to you by Dove men plus care
guys do you get distracted during the
day thinking about your underarm
sweating or itching or emitting an odor
oh
do those thoughts keep you from showing
care when it counts new and improved
Dove men plus care antiperspirant with
72 hours sweat and odor protection and
one quarter moisturizing cream helps you
forget about your underarms so you can
be present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improved Dove men plus
care antiperspirant or ever personal
care products are sold this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection
you do Impressions yes sir how many
Impressions do you have that you can bam
well less less and less because I don't
I don't like I don't consider myself an
impressionist like I said like uh yeah
I'm a copycat I'm a minute I'm a mimic I
can hear something you can't do that to
you yeah yeah yeah
um and and the skill set of like finding
a hook or finding uh what makes that
person funny kind of thing like like
that as is an earned skill I guess but
otherwise I'm just like yeah just make
noises and it's not that big a deal you
know
um off you know I could if you like I
could do 10 probably like that I go like
let's name some that you're really great
Jack Black people love me we just saw
the Jack Black we love that who else
um Kristoff Waltz I like doing that I
was like oh hello it's very good to be
here Michael on your podcast that you
are doing because you are very
knowledgeable yes I am gonna learn that
that is great what do you smile it's
sort of through the job
it's like a Rolex
slowly go up and then you're falling
down yes wow you know what I used to do
is like uh next get the square yeah
Pauline that's great one yeah yeah hey
Charlotte I know I'm from Charlotte yeah
Charlotte's Web yeah Charlotte it says
scrumptious
I don't know if we could say this but
did I say this on the air before when uh
somebody told me that uh a kid was
running down up and down the aisle first
class in a plane and Paul Lin finally
gets up and turns to the kid's mother
and goes if your son comes running by me
again I'm gonna [__] him
[Laughter]
absolutely it's not I think you can keep
that that's what he said it was a
different time different time
um who else
um I really like doing Brad Pitt and
it's you did ones that no one does
that's always what I tried to do and and
it it comes from wanting to be him and
there's this scene in seven where he and
Morgan Freeman are at the bar and he
goes you know I don't think you're
quitting because you believe that I
think you want to believe that because
you're quitting
you want me to say yeah yeah yeah it's
[__] the world is [__] which all go
live in a [__] log cabin but I don't
agree with you
I do not
thanks for the beer but you know it's
amazing if you look at you you see that
yeah yeah see it yeah the way he does
that yeah it's like that yeah so mine
very quickly became this and the bear
comes from 12 Monkeys which is like you
want to escape that scene that's very
same monkey Monk
gee get out of my chair yeah and he does
like a lot of that God but I mean I just
love I just love it he's my movies
Brad Pitt yes does Kobe uh your wife
your lovely wife who was on Smallville I
know that's another thing where I'm like
oh maybe we're always supposed to meet
because if I'd gotten Pete then we would
have met shooting in Vancouver yeah but
um does she love when you do Impressions
um I don't think
which one does she like if she had what
is she like uh you know her support of
me is like omnipresent like I never
don't feel supported loved or whatever
you do but she yeah yeah yeah does she
love you even or she pretend well when
you've done something where you know it
wasn't funny where it bombed it's like
you're not funny and she's honest with
you no she doesn't do that like maybe
maybe like I'm like okay give me
feedback she'll be like I love it you're
great you know like she's that she's so
she wouldn't be like she wouldn't like
tell you if you weren't good yeah she'd
be like uh yeah what if you're pitching
something instead of it's already on
screen she she is
I don't know that I would do that for an
impression but she's certainly like the
first person I take ideas for scriptures
yeah like
and and I do think she's very Discerning
and very helpful with that
um but no she is she yeah she she's like
thumbs up on all things except my
football passion she's got Rams yeah you
love the Rams love the right you're
happy last year I was the most happy one
last year and now I'm not quite last
place happy I think there's a I think
the Patriot fans sorry if you're Patriot
fans by the way the Giants beat them
both in both the Super Bowls yeah Annie
who look they're one of the best
franchises ever uh Tom Brady is the best
quarterback in history but I think that
no one wants to see the winners keep
winning I'm always the one that if you
pick me on a softball team or a flag
football team or I want to be The
Underdogs I want to come back and beat
you or at least I don't want to be the
ones that like are always winning I
don't so it's almost like you guys won
have a few losing Seasons yeah
I I just I read this and if it's true I
love it she toured with Charlie Daniels
man she was a backup singer
do you know a lot of their songs not a
ton Devil Went Down to Georgia okay if I
said the line
granny because your dog bite no child no
okay that's what he says did you know
that no grenade
okay does your dog bite no I listened to
that part of the song 60 times yeah
cassette tape to hear what they were
saying I love those kinds of things I
love what the hell did they just say and
then it lasts forever like Hush Hush eye
to eye like
Hush Hush eye to eye it could be I
didn't know that but
um this is the biggest one and I only
discovered it in the last couple like
maybe during the pandemic Love Actually
I don't know if you're a fan I find it I
love it I love the movie The Love the
movie okay what song um not a song a
line of dialogue
Emma Thompson confronting Alan Rickman
and she goes what would you do if you
were in my situation anything else what
situation is that and she goes what if
you found out that your next husband had
purchased a gold necklace and on come
Christmas giving it to somebody else and
she like calls him out and then he would
always go
um like that like you can't hear what
he's saying really and he's saying I'm
sir in the wrong I'm so in the wrongs
that's amazing was your mom uh were your
parents very supportive were they always
there I know your dad had Ambitions to
be an actor but so that's how it started
they were like did they kind of put you
in the Limelight right away my mom yeah
my mom was I think my father always
supportive but it really was my mom who
was like I'm gonna take you three little
kids to a commercial agent just because
you're precocious and cute and I think
and my younger two siblings like
immediately were like nope then I was
like yeah sure
she was like fine you guys don't have to
do it yeah if you would have said no she
would have been done oh and and did
frequently too like auditioned for like
a year in town when I was really young
and I was like this boring and we
stopped and then we moved to Big Bear
and then a movie shot up there and they
needed extras and so like and my older
sister was working for the casting agent
so she's like do you want to be in the
movie I was like yeah what movie it's
called a pig's tale a pig's tale with a
young Andrew Keegan oh wow
um uh yeah uh do you know Andrew leads
by chance now he's he was on um he was
on what was the Infinite Playlist
there you go
um but yeah so like and I was a camper
and then got an agent back and was like
yeah that's fun let's go and got some
small jobs and got into the union and
then was like I just want to go to high
school hey yeah back to high school went
to UCLA all the things so you were just
and you were taking singing classes and
dance and all that stuff yeah you can
you're a good dancer
um with choreography I can learn
choreography well quickly yes could you
do not that you will but could you
dancing with the stars and pretty much
kill it
and what'd you do I think I could do
well I don't think I'd do it no yeah why
not
um
I like being known for making something
not not being me
I agree with you I agree with you I I
don't mind being a host of something yep
I don't mind like there's I may do this
thing where I'm sort of like a host on
the road doing something you're shining
a light on work that you like yeah like
interesting things yes that's different
yes but like and now Michael Rosenbaum
will do the
yes one step two steps it's why I don't
do stand up I don't think I like I I
don't I don't have the connection or the
drive or that I don't feel fed by me
going like you know what I think about
Paul what anything right
um that doesn't but but you know I saw
Batman when I was seven years old
Michael Keaton yes yeah of course and
him him draw the the muggers are looking
through the wallet and he drops down
behind the smoke and I was like magic is
real and I want to be involved in making
things that don't exist feel real and
then later feel funny feel magical feel
emotional
um so I like that so but but but I I
loathe to ever assume anybody knows who
I am cares who I am or or have any
entitlement about you want to play
characters I would I love to I love to
act I love to perform I love to tell
stories
um I love to make people laugh
but not like by just cracking jokes as
tearing I like I like you don't like
while you're out with people to start
you don't like tell jokes to people
I do I like laughing with friends yeah I
don't like occupying a conversation
oh that kind of makes sense yeah
yeah you don't you don't you don't care
to be the same I want to share in
something I want to share in something I
don't want to I don't have that and and
and obviously like I grapple with the
hypocrisy of like yeah you don't want
any attention
in your 20 years of professional
television and film performing but yeah
there there is I don't know I have my
own weird definition of like
there's a skill set that I have honed
and worked on and have opinions on I
have tricks on and feel things that work
and don't work and voice speech movement
character physicality set design props
hair make up all the magic of that
the these are real trades to me I feel
like you can argue for those
um being a celebrity
doesn't I is there's no attractiveness
for me I understand the appeal of it and
there are celebrities that I love right
but for me either that's not a want I
have for myself did you want to be
famous
yes because I'm glad you said that go
ahead but why I want the Opera the
professional opportunity that comes from
that I don't need the free tickets or
restaurant reservations or people on the
street but I do want director I respect
and love thinking of me because of the
work he's seen and going like he's he's
gonna be uh God I wish I could get work
with him but why not have both why not
because I don't think you can have one
without well I think uh I love character
work I love jumping into a character I
love diving deep and all that stuff I
trained and I did all that but I I don't
when somebody comes up and says oh yeah
dude hey I love your work no I know you
that's not exactly right but when you
said the free tickets I take advantage
of that if somebody wants to give me
free passes to Disney World with my
friends and family yes a 20 000 free
trip yeah I'm in if somebody wants to
fly me to Europe for free to make you
know to come to a restaurant and say
hello load of you I'm in I'm a [__]
like that I'm I'm cool with that to
because I feel like wow this may go away
tomorrow totally so yeah and I'm also a
bit of a ham I like that kind of thing
yeah yeah but uh but go ahead well no I
mean like for me I used the status that
I'd achieved through my career to become
a Club 33 member right like Disneyland
like that but that is like I also like
have to pay for it right right there's
an earned thing about it and and listen
that's not to say that you know I've
never
I've never benefited from the free stuff
but that is by no means the drive for me
whatsoever and and quite honestly I
still do if I'm giving a free Mexico
vacation there is never been a better
Tipper in all of of course in all of
history of course you know what I mean
because like
um yeah yeah that's just that's just a
good person all right that's just a good
man a good human being I never
understood I I've always been a big
Tipper I've always yeah wanted to go
above and beyond I want people to Yes uh
just feel appreciated because they are
and and again like to use your example
of hey man I love your on the street
like
there is nothing more flattering and I
also have a very good comprehension that
like you are the lifeblood you you
coming up and saying I like that is the
only reason I'm allowed to do what I
love doing and live very privileged
because of that but you don't need it
you don't have to have it no it's it's I
don't I don't walk out expecting it I
don't you know what I mean yeah and that
is a very different thing like that is
someone who wants celebrity is like the
entitlement of people should know the do
you know who I am energy I am always I
operate from uh you probably don't know
who I am yes I I I I do too I think that
I I forget all about it until someone
says Hey Oh and I snap at it oh yeah
yeah I guess I was that guy yeah so
that's how I go to the mall I'm hanging
out with my friends I want to go to the
food court I want to sit in the chair at
Brookstone uh you know I I just want to
be a regular person and sometimes people
see me and it snaps me out of it but I
go right back into being so I'm able to
do that now I think there was a part of
me when I got more Fame that it was like
it was more it was happening more often
that it was hard I was always recognized
I was bald I stuck out like a sore thumb
and I kind of like
yeah I was always in it because people
are always saying talking to me yeah
it's just hard to go back into what did
you feel was there a distinct exist like
a distinction in the existence for you
like in Vancouver from June till March
versus when you come home more or less
then like like traveling I find when I'm
in small towns is where people are like
what the hell are you doing here yeah
small towns for sure yeah uh Vancouver
it was really were they like used to it
because you're also up there so much and
like and I feel like at that point in
Vancouver that was like the jewel
production really you know no one really
no one really bothered me yeah every
once in a while somebody would say hey
yeah but you know I I think that's what
saved me and saved a lot of the actors
on the show is that 10 months a year we
were away from everybody yeah we were
away from the Sunset Strip and the clubs
and the all these things I wasn't
I don't know what I'd do I was a young
guy and I was lost and I you know I I
was immature I'm still immature I don't
know what I would have done I think I'm
responsible I have a good head on my
shoulders but uh I think it it moves for
the better yeah I I'm thankful that I
was away doing those things a
distraction was good now I want to film
hopefully here so I could have my home
and my my doggy and my friends I don't
really want to leave I'm dealing with
that right now it's like we filming
Toronto
Toronto yeah yeah I don't know yeah the
material isn't that good yeah you know
yeah yeah but yeah I understand I
understand you you're one of those guys
who you want to create you want to
become a character you want to uh it's
it's
you love what you do you love the craft
I could see that yeah you love working
yes do you think that your confidence
level has because I I could answer this
question and that's why I asked this
because my feeling my confidence level
has sort of lessened gone down a little
bit over the years sure as I get older
and older I don't know why because when
I was young I was sort of that guy that
we talked about earlier that comes up
it's like hey what's going on yeah yeah
I don't care I'm here I'm gonna make it
I'm a star yes um and then something
it's still that I could I could
approachable I'm
but something uh
I don't know if I just got tired of it
or if I just got
I don't know what it is I think I know
what you're saying because and I think
my answer is yes
um I think my arrogant confidence has
diminished significantly and that's not
to poo poo that I think arrogant
confidence is necessary to handle the
rejection which is where you started
yeah to go like no I'm great no I'll do
it fine oh you know I could I could do
it better I could I'm the best one for
that there has to be some of that to do
what we do yeah there does like you're
just in nature in the nature of
entertainment the entertainment business
of show
everybody who participates somewhere in
some way and however they Define it for
themselves as like
I'm worth looking at yeah it doesn't
mean like yeah I'm worth listening to so
the air like the
similarly like certainly through my 20s
into my early 30s the idea of like I
know how to do it best yep that has gone
away of now it's I know how to do it how
I like might not be the right way might
not be the most popular way but where I
have gained is just sort of like like
the earned confidence of repetition
right of just like yeah I've put in the
Reps I've put in the time I've I know
what it takes to do that and it allows
me to
it allows me to kind of like
not get too upset about rejection but
also to maybe not put myself out there
where I would before yeah which I think
there's a downside to that because I'm
certain that many jobs I went out for in
my early career I was like like Mad TV
is a great example like I'm not gonna
get this I don't deserve and it worked
or you meet the casting director who
goes I love you not this thing but the
next thing I bring you you know that
happened a lot for me and now I'm just
like I have to drive where yeah isn't
that something yeah you know I wrote
this down while you were talking I was
listening yes but something I will
forget that I drew you I drew a picture
of you and I want to share it with the
audience
um no it is uh
it's it's the difference between
rejection accepting rejection being good
at rejection and being good at failure
and that that came up because I thought
no one I'm not gonna say no one but I am
really great at when someone says no I
mean it hurts a little bit like if a
girl doesn't want to go out with me a
second time I'm like we had a great date
I need to know why what happened yeah I
don't get crazy I just kind of feel bad
yeah I'm like ah that kind of sucks it
happened yeah uh not that long ago
um but
but I could deal with rejection when
someone says uh I don't get a call back
or I don't get the part I let it go I
forget about it yeah my mother doesn't
that's why I don't tell her anything
what happened to Private Ryan
who's 30 years ago it's over
but but here's the difference
failure hurts a little more
because I you know when I do something
and I put my heart into it and I feel
like I've done the best I could and I
think I'm pretty good and I think
everybody's good and and then it airs
and then it gets canceled after a couple
of Seasons I think it's not that it
I don't it just feels like
ah that was on me that was on me so
maybe they maybe they don't want to see
me as much I wish I wish to let that go
I wish for you you dealt with failure
you have a show recently so much single
uh single parents two seasons two
seasons gone yeah
yeah people an audience didn't connect
and it could be a million things it
could be a million things and it could
be me but
the friendships the friendships the uh
the
um the income the the stability the
structure the shooting in town like you
said the doing a job with people I
really liked like across the board and
it feeling like reasonable hours like
there's so much thank goodness for those
two years and you also learn like what
about that scenario would I want to
recreate what would I not want to and
how do I
you know use that to make choices moving
forward I mean I I do hear what you're
saying and I'm I if I'm being completely
honest probably have felt similarly at
times but
I'm at a place now like with my children
where I'm encouraging failure as much as
possible right because the oh God yeah
the the idea to do it right right away
or the idea to be good at it right away
or I'm not into it
I want my daughters to have exposure and
have access to as many passion skills
subjects as possible but to understand
it will take time effort putting in reps
putting in the hours to get better at it
then nobody starts
perfect right no and and perfect is not
a non-existent thing anyway but nobody
starts as a master of something you have
to earn that and you there's no I I
I bet um I'm a certain I'm 100 confident
no one became a master without ever
failing once I I agree and probably the
Masters failed more than anybody else
and just didn't let the idea that it was
them get in their way I think it took me
a long time
I think I was lucky in the sense that
I started acting and immediately I was
funny and people liked me and I started
getting cast and everything and and but
and things just took off yeah after we
got that retainer after we got that
return yeah yeah you know it's funny
because I remember my manager that day
on on set he goes hey I really think you
should fix your teeth whoa
what he goes listen it's it's character
it's fine uh you're a good looking guy
your teeth are crooked and I think if
you straighten them out you get leading
roles so I said [__] it put on retainer
six months later I started getting lead
roles boom it worked wow but
that failure
um
didn't happen till late and then once I
I felt like I failed like I can't do it
that I was I I wish I would have
experienced more failure at a young age
sure because I just didn't yeah a
failure family failure I mean you know
tons of dysfunction tons of failure that
matters yeah you're not smart you're not
this so maybe that was like you know
felt like failure I was a failure so
maybe there's that but yes anyway that's
interesting uh here's here here's also
um maybe a life hack maybe a cheat maybe
a shortcut
uh because because certainly I get down
on my certainly I go like why is this
not happening enough why is there not
more of whatever
uh look around you you know like like
look around and and look at the world
and immediately go like oh I'm so lucky
I'm so yeah you have I'm so fortuitous
I'm so lucky you know like that alone
really sort of holds me in check and
that's really like I feel that comes
from Kobe who's maybe the most grounded
person I've ever met she sings that she
like she goes in every Wednesday she
goes and works at a soup kitchen just
because she won't she does it every week
oh my she like and that's been her since
I met her so it's that of like what
really matters what's real what matters
what will we remember
yeah yeah because like how many times do
you see those Instagram things or hear
about yeah we interviewed 5 000 old
people on their deathbeds yeah here's
what the one thing they regret yeah I
work too much yeah yeah or I I didn't
laugh enough yeah I didn't travel enough
I didn't get the Ed Burns part in Saving
Private Ryan
I did get a call back for that stuff I
thought I was gonna get it and uh
Goodwill Hunting great and I didn't get
that there's a demon gun he wrote it no
it wasn't for that part but a lot a lot
of big Parts I was like oh my God I
didn't get that I didn't get that you
know I I I I I was always good with that
not getting parts yeah um you know
what's funny is this is flying by and I
really haven't I I wanna you have to
leave I I eventually well eventually
family yeah I mean I said an hour so we
have like 10 minutes but maybe 15 yes
yes yeah so I I don't know what it is I
just really like talking to you likewise
this is so easy this has kind of been in
the works for a while too I mean I'm so
glad you emailed me back and said hey
yeah yeah and you're like you did and uh
then I saw you funny enough at uh uh
Dave Desmond dust mulching yeah his
party I think it's Cusack I think that's
cool but we saw each other there and you
with Kobe and you were dressed up as
werewolves yeah I was like a wolf man
she was a vampire vampires right yeah
and it was awesome and you're like hey
it's terrible I loved it oh my God I
don't recognize
serendipitous things yeah it was awesome
yeah I want to get just a little bit
into SNL that was that was a harder
audition right
um yeah it's probably the hardest
audition I've ever done how many times
you go in I had to do the test three
times in front of Lauren yeah three
times in front of Lauren yes and how
long does this take five minutes the
actual audition itself yeah you don't
want to go too far past between five and
seven minutes I think is probably the
ideal once you're over 10 minutes you
know unless you're something super
special it's kind of like you didn't get
it
um and what'd you do a lot of different
things when he first saw me and he had
come to the Groundlings to see Naseem
um because I think Tina Fey recommended
her to Lauren so he came to the Sunday
company we were performing there he came
to a show he flew four of us out I did
um I forget because of the three ones
but I I always did at least two or three
original pieces characters either like
characters from sketches I did at
Groundlings or like dumb silly bits that
I'd come up with and then I always try
to do more Impressions just to show
variety and show relevancy what
Impressions did you did you do that the
third time the third time God the third
time was interesting I
I I think like I threw Brad in there I
maybe did Michael Sarah uh Michael Sarah
quickly do a Sarah
oh so great just just a bunch of guys
sort of sort of hanging out and just
just podding it up talking about about
fan ship and and sort of what what
inspires you I guess at the end of the
day that's the most important part right
that's great okay because you did Sarah
um at one point I did
Dr Claw from Inspector Gadget having
phone sex with Paul Giamatti oh my God
uh what is that just like okay uh I
guess I I put my hand on your thigh yes
yes more okay uh I take it out I spit on
it
oh yes
I'll get you Giamatti oh my God oh my
God like I think I did Seth Rogen at one
point I certainly did Jack Black at one
point uh I did Tom Hanks which is like
well you've gotta be
[Applause]
did you think you were going to get it
after that third audition you're like uh
well I kind of after Mad TV because I
only did really like just over half of a
season there I was asked back but like
at a reduced thing and my reps were like
don't do it and I was like oh okay and I
was like why did I do that and they
weren't paying you well there no way
they were paying me three thousand
dollars more a week than when I got SNL
10 years later so I made more on Mad TV
per week than than when I started
getting paid at SNL you know that's
crazy yeah uh quickly the uh the um
Atkinson jebedi uh Atkinson he
introduced me to that oh cool okay
[__] funny yeah that was fun to do I
mean good Lord and of course
the sloppy swish like went viral and
crazy yeah people ever come up to you
and say can you do the sloppy switch
they like that that's a good one yes yes
people like that and they also we did
and this was not like on the show but
Robin was a musical guest and we
recreated the call your girlfriend video
Yeah in our office down had you on right
maybe a couple times I don't think for
that I don't know if I don't know for
that but wow do you think of these
things a lot I mean on your own like do
they just come to you Kiki was me
um to be fair like doing the robin thing
was also actually Sarah Schneider who
ended up being head writer for a year
and then she created the other two which
was really funny if you haven't watched
it watch it you created that with Chris
Kelly Sarah was the one because I was
obsessed with that song and I would
interrupt people knowing that Robin was
coming the following week I'd go into
people's offices and like turn the video
on and be like how great is this dance
party dance party they'll be like we're
trying to work it out of our office but
Sarah was the one like you should just
try to recreate that video in your
office and I said I'm stealing that I'm
doing it yes were you intimidated yeah
every day did you feel intimidated SNL
for me it wasn't fun was it going in
there every day
sometimes sometimes it was the most fun
it really was and mad tv helped me
because going into SNL like I would say
the first two years I knew to just like
appreciate every day sit in the pocket
do good work put your best foot forward
and you know but understand this is you
know there are seniors and you're a
freshman and understand that
um
SNL was really kind of the first time
where I it made me a level of insecure I
had not experienced before like I'd
certainly had always had healthy
insecurity
but SNL for me and having done some work
since I was off of it I've sort of
realized I cared so much what everybody
thought of me because
I loved that job and I love that place
and and everybody was so funny and so
smart and by the end of it it put me in
not it I was not my best self in that I
was just really
um it turned me into a pessimist and I
would not have
describe myself that way before that job
and it broke you down a little bit Yeah
Yeah by the end of it by the end of it
it was it was also like having two kids
you know it's not it's not it's a Young
Person's show it's a show that I think
wants all of you and and kind of
deserves all of you that's the best way
to do it is that like you're there as
much as you can be and you're available
for everything and then when on the off
weeks you're hanging out with everybody
and you're planning trips to Europe
Costa Rica whatever you know you're
bonding and I was I just by Nature by
having a child by being you know having
a fiance at that point I was like a
clock in clock out kind of guy and by
the time my family moved out there
you know for the first four seasons I
was flying back and forth and so I'd be
out there and do the job I could let it
consume me and then I'd come back and
there was some adjustment stuff that was
tough but then once my family was out
there it's like I gotta get to the
Winter concert I gotta I put so much
time in this my time is now more
precious to me
um which is you know which is true but
also like
not true for the rest of the show you
know what I mean so yeah it's a tricky
thing but the friends I made there the
experiences I had there like I will
never have a job as special or or that I
have more Pride about because it was the
dream job like that is speaking about
failure oh my God that's that is and I
think probably will forever be the
biggest success of my life is setting
out and going like I have a shot at this
if I train and I put myself to be in the
right place at the right time as often
as possible I have a good shot at it and
and they've got it and it worked did
were you in a sense relieved when they
didn't renew your contract yes you were
like good yes did they know you didn't
want to come back yes they knew so it
was a mutual thing there was it was
still like messy and you know lacking of
clarity or respect and all that but it
was not I was not taken by surprise by
any means did Lauren call you and say I
just want to say that you were great no
nothing like that nope it's not in his
nature to do that sometimes but I think
by that point our relationship was a
little
um
we just did not have that closeness at
that point who is the funniest person on
SNL at the time in your opinion at the
time the person who made me laugh the
hardest when I was there Tim Robinson
Tim Robinson he cracked you up more than
anybody he you know he was on the cast
for a year and then he wrote for the
rest basically the rest of the time I
was there
and he and Zach Cannon who he wrote a
majority of stuff with and created I
think you should leave
made me laugh the hardest the people you
know yeah are you still close to them I
don't I haven't talked to him in a while
but I love him and and he's great I'm
very close with Bobby I'm very close
with Vanessa very close with Jay kind of
like the class that I came in with
that's who I'm
um you produce scripted directed starred
in the comic Hitman film killing Gunther
yes which 2017. yeah
I directed a movie where I starred wrote
uh all that directed and I honestly
thought I was going to die yeah I was so
exhausted how did you get through that
were you do you remember being so tired
like you couldn't finish it or you were
fine I mean yeah I didn't find that as
much like the the stamina I had for it
because I think like to get it made I
kind of had to be its biggest
cheerleader and I had to be like this is
gonna be great it's going great I love
it this is awesome we'll do that you
know it's just that sort of like
willpower like yes I can do this
um but speaking to failure like that's
certainly like I see that as a as a
failure but a very Noble one and a very
informative one like the what I learned
in that experience and that process as
well as like how much fun I had making
it and it actually was very fun and you
hired your friends you hired Kobe your
wife yeah I mean that's what it and shot
in Vancouver her hometown I mean
unbelievable got to work with Arnold
Schwarzenegger who like I stand by that
like if you watch the film from when he
enters to the end like I go like no this
is really funny I'm very proud of this
that's all that matters yeah same thing
with mine I mean it just like it was one
of those raunchy comedies Sandler s
comedy made for very little money 800
000 yeah I'm so proud of it it's exactly
what I wanted to make I shot 100 pages
in eight days I'm proud of myself
incredible I really am and that's yeah
that's how you should be and you got
Arnold Schwarzenegger to be in your
movie by the way was he a nice guy yes
he was always cool the most professional
he was never short with you like enough
enough ticks no and and never that way
with any of the crew and you could feel
back to our conversation of like the
person who walks up like hi and the
Jitters and the nervousness everybody
could not wait for him to be on set and
he was so generous and so he's also such
a pro he's such a star that he kind of
knows how to naturally go like okay okay
well but also like I love that yeah it's
a good one the president if it bleeds
okay I'll see you around I'll see you
goodbye you know like and do that and
he's told you we're done but you feel
great about it yes you know he was in
True Lies Of course and my friend uh Tom
Arnold was with him and uh he showed up
late to set he showed up very late to
set he came in he's sitting in the car
with Tom Arnold I believe and James
Cameron comes up to him and goes you're
[__] you [__] the whole day you
being [__] late you're [__] me
you're [__] me and he walked away and
Arnold goes dude what the [__] why don't
you beat the [__] out of him you're
gonna let him talk to you like that he
goes he was right
and that was it wow he was right wow it
was unbelievable yeah that's I love that
he was really good to you he was on time
if he was an [__] that would have
been made it Torture right exactly we
did a lot of like I all of all our prep
and there was a lot of that most our
most uh focused prep went into his
arrival and his his week with us and
like get him get it but he showed up
with alts his own like ideas for things
he was the best did he get paid a lot
yes a lot of money yes probably yeah
uh okay when you met Kobe on How I Met
Your Mother you were doing how many
episodes I met her before that for that
I met her I had shot a pilot about a
month before she shot that pilot right
and my co-lead was a Canadian actor
friend of hers Paul Campbell and she
came to the taping of our show and I was
feeling very confident about its chances
and David janellari was like this is
definitely gonna happen old WB was like
this is great it's my favorite of the
season
um and then she and I met there hung out
at a birthday party a month later and
she's like yeah I'm starting this pilot
next week myself I'm like yeah well good
luck with that you know yeah one of the
biggest shows nine years later
um and and no but we hit it off our
first date was like the night after her
pilot table read like we went out for a
date it went very well and she's like I
like you but just know I'm gonna focus
on the first night we kissed the first
night the kid it was a nice kiss it was
a really nice kiss yeah do you remember
driving home going
I want to marry this girl no or I really
like we were 22 when we met but
certainly certainly jittery excited all
the butterflies like a year into our
relationship I broke up with her
only because I had like a young man
freak out where I'm like uh I can't be
done I can't be done I'm only 23 24.
this can't be it I broke up over there
for two days and 48 hours less drove
over to her house crying and going like
I'm sorry I'm sorry and that was it well
I just promised her I said here's what I
was I didn't want to be done having sex
with different people for the rest of my
life that's a stupid reason to break up
and I promise you if I don't want to
lose this that because it feels too good
you know what I mean I don't want to
lose something because it feels too like
it could be great forever so if you give
me a second chance I will act like it's
gonna be forever and I won't look for
the out or the other and I will work on
that that is the most
[__] honest response that I just want
to have sex with other people and that
was my reason I had that and I lost the
girl yeah I had that where I I realized
it but it was too late I remember
calling her saying I just I I I've been
thinking about this and I just miss you
so much and and and and this is it and
and I'm an idiot and I knew that I kept
thinking about it I missed her and then
I tried to get back with her and she had
gone back to her ex and then a shitstorm
happened for a year where it was just
like uh so it didn't work out yeah now
she's married with two kids and I love
her to death and we're really good
friends and oh God she's an amazing
human being but I'm glad it worked out
for you I just yeah I kept the window
short I didn't I didn't walk it too long
yeah
all right this is really quick okay [__]
talking with Taryn kill him great these
are my patrons they're rapid fire great
they are the top tiers join patreon.com
uh inside of you you guys help the
podcast more than you know I appreciate
you talk up to your Super Sam I was so
excited when my son started watching
nature cat and I heard your voice was
that an SNL project so many great SNL
voices in that show thank you so much I
where I have to go after this is a
nature cat recording session really yeah
that's what I go to after this I think
uh uh David and Adam Rudman who who are
brothers that created the show love SNL
and so they got SNL people to do it
um but it happened very organically and
and it's such a great sweet show that
I'm very proud voice of nature cat tally
nature cat
you could just pop in like that I love
it uh Leanne what do slash did you enjoy
most about being on SNL you've sort of
said and Mad TV um
uh similar to both I loved the access to
the musical performances which like
watching from home wasn't ever
necessarily my favorite thing but if you
can watch prince from 15 feet away with
like nobody else around you I highly
recommend it Michelle K what's it like
being born on April Fool's Day pretty
good I've only been like fooled once and
it wasn't that funny I went to an Arts
High School and like all the drama kids
thought they'd get me really good so
they created this this drama where my
carpool right like my friend Sarah who's
like my buddy my carpool that she had
gone gotten pregnant and was freaking
out and didn't know and was in tears and
sobbing and it was dramatic and then
they're like I got you yeah right and I
was like okay
Raj tell me about a skit idea you
pitched at SNL you thought was so funny
but never made it to rehearsal or air I
really love chatting late uh with Murray
Head Murray Head sings the song One
Night yeah and so this was a talk show
where Murray Head was the Johnny Carson
and it turned out that that's not him
saying that's just how he always talks
so he'd be like hell um my guess is Mike
Rosenbaum and I'm gonna say it's very
nice to be here I love your house and
other paraphernalia is enjoyable cats
did you use electric razors or was it
always with Gillette slick
if I get my kicks below the above the
waistline Sunshine dude I I to me
absolutely [__] brilliant to a lot of
people probably like I don't get it yep
and I certainly I think it's brilliant
we did it took care of it I love it
thank you we did it address and the cue
card guys were like that's the best
thing you've ever done I know I was like
that's all like the smart people like
that yeah Dev Nixon Taryn any particular
souvenir from your scrubs time oh no not
from Scrubs unfortunately which is which
is shameful because Bill Lawrence uh
created the show that led to me meeting
Kobe and I love Bill and
now just want to be on Ted lasso uh who
doesn't uh last but not least Hamilton
okay how long did you do Hamilton three
months three months why three months
um three months was supposed to do it
six
we were moving from New York to LA at
the end of summer so I was going to do
it from January in through the end of
summer and then Kobe got a play on
Broadway which was the best and what
she'd been trying to achieve since we'd
moved there three years earlier and she
got to do a Noel coward play with Kevin
Kline and it was like I was like you
have to do this but and we overlapped
for about a month which was great
because we had built-in Day dates like
between the matinee and show of
Wednesday in the matinee show of
Saturday we'd go on these dates and it
was like one of the most magical
crossovers of personal professional for
us ever
but our two children had no Mom or Dad
for six nights of the week to tuck them
in at not you know and so I was like
I'll I'll duck out so you told him you
gave him notice I got it and they hired
someone else and you helped them out
yeah yeah they brought they brought back
in uh uh
Brian Darcy James Brian James Darcy
Brian James thank you
um who had originally done at the public
before Groff even
you did eight shows a week
were you exhausted no I was the king so
I was like I did 10 minutes of stage
time you know singing the same song but
you loved it it's it was the most
fulfilled and joyful experience ever
really yeah that's one that you'll never
forget ever and you do it again in a
heartbeat as soon as my girls are
launched into the world I think both
Kobe and I would like to migrate back
east and and see if we can jump back in
if they'll have us again but like I was
I was such an I was so excited such a
fan about it that I would run to the
other side of the stage when I was off
stage and go up to like they had a
rehearsal room because they'd like do a
a sing-through for the understudies and
swings and I'd just like go up and
listen they're like what are you doing
here and I'm like I just love being a
part of the show and so like they gave
me uh an award when I left that said
most social Kings you're an anomaly yeah
you are an anomaly what's next
um I'm working on the pylon for Prime
video every Wednesday we do a comedy
show about this week in football which
is I'm loving and we do it every week
and it's to promote Thursday Night
Football on Prime but wow we're you know
the lunatics are running the Asylum and
we're doing it we did a Sondheim opening
the other day let this most recent
episode is
um my co-host Sarah Tiana which is so
funny
I will I definitely agree
um the women took over the NFL like all
things female which was it's really good
and funny and I'm proud of it and doing
that and then I'm in a movie that comes
out next May called River Wild it's a
remake of the Meryl Streep movie really
yeah River Wild yeah yeah yeah is it fun
it was really fun we shot in hungry and
and
um Slovakia and Bosnia who's in it Adam
uh Brody Leighton Meester myself wow um
yeah yeah good for you man yeah what's
your handle what's the Instagram handle
uh Instagram is at Tarzan no Z because
that's how I tell people to spell my
name Tarzan no Z follow him he's
brilliant he's I can't thank you enough
this is you already have no this is
truly amazing oh good good yeah this is
a joy it was really a joy did you have
fun Ryan oh my God yeah I mean so
informational I mean I could have talked
to you forever this is the wrong thing
this is the longest podcast I've done
all year oh it's an hour and ten oh God
sorry you should be thanks buddy thank
you bye
foreign
what can you say love that guy truly
enjoyed I remember certain guests and I
remember just his smile his energy
uh his natural ability to be funny
without trying
to possess that
sharply dressed too yeah looks what's
the words
Swanky swanky
really nice Taryn you look really
healthy uh thanks for listening to the
podcast and again we couldn't do this
without the top tier patrons who make
the show possible if you want to support
the show go to patreon.com inside of you
and also visit the inside of you online
store for awesome merch Smallville and
inside emerge
and uh May early May I'll be in Wales
and then Tidewater Virginia Beach and
then a lot of more cons coming up
throughout the year but uh I'm also in
the Cameo check me out uh I don't really
promote Cameo but I'm on it I get
requests
I get good ones too
I believe it yeah I get good ones here
are the shout outs top tier patrons love
you and uh there are a lot of benefits
to being a member you get you get boxes
from me personalized notes for me uh
YouTube lives with me
with other patrons zooms
um you get your name shouted out uh I
hope that people are enjoying it a lot
of patrons the top tiers especially have
stuck around for a long long time so I
hope I'm doing something right here we
go shout outs to these special people
Nancy D Leah asks little Lisa let me see
if I could do radio voice
[Music]
Nancy D Lee Hess a little Lisa you Kiko
Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert P Jason W
Sophie M Raj C
Joshua D I just auditioned for Rick and
Morty yeah that'd be cool to get if I
can't tell you who I auditioned for
Joshua D Jennifer N Stacy L Jamal F
Janelle B Mike e l Don Supremo 99 more
San Diego m
Tom Lally will get a free chicken dinner
from Grandy's over on Green River Road
if you can tell me this next song
or the Grandy's was a restaurant in
Indiana yeah I got that Chad W Leanne P
Janine R Maya P Maddie s Belinda and
Dave H Sheila G Brad d Ray Nate correct
Tabitha Tom and Liliana hey Talia
I'm not I don't remember M correct Betsy
D Chad d l u Angel M Rhiannon C Cory K
devnex and Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D
Joey M blank and Leah
Eugene correct
Corey Heather
L yes you know Locklear Jake
uh B Megan T Angela F male s Orlando C
Caroline R Christine s Eric H Shane R
Andrew M Tim L Karina and Amanda R Jen B
Kevin e Stephanie K jorel jam and J
Leanne J Luna R Cindy e Mike F Stone
Aaron R hello Aaron and Katie Kendall L
house J Meredith I Charlene C Cara C
Mary R Sheena L Jessica B Kyle F Marisol
P Esteban G Kaylee J Megan K Mickey L
and Brian a love you guys thank you for
listening today couldn't do it without
you and uh from Michael Rosemont here in
the Hollywood Hills of California well
I'm also Ryan tears I'm here too
we love you Ryan say it
uh uh
um
yep there it is
be good to yourselves
be good to yourself
[Music]